what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay um I am recording this off my
laptop because I am moving right now so
hopefully there's no real degradation in
terms of quality so we are picking up
with damage really the the second volume
of damage is really where this is it's
kind of interesting so for those of you
guys who were new to comic books overall
usually when it comes to introducing a
character it'll only ever happen in one
of two ways either it'll happen in terms
of them like appearing as a backup
feature or part of a main story and the
other thing is that is that usually that
it's kind of do like a miniseries right
like they'll really kind of like a short
volume they'll say okay we're gonna
write like six issues and then we're
gonna test the waters with these six
issues and we're gonna see what happens
now in modern days Marvel just cancels
after six issues instead of changing up
writers which is what they used to do
which is why so many of the stories you
know really kind of had a lot more a lot
more of a dynamic than they do right now
a lot of them seem really
two-dimensional but DC is is really kind
of always kind of get to that trend it's
kind of weird here but with regards to
damage that's what we had the first
three issues were the introduction to
his character but we didn't really know
his origin we just kind of knew he was
there and he was a byproduct of an
experiment what this does is it kind of
expands on the first three issues and
then really sort of builds up on his
character that's kind of the cool thing
here is it's really being taken at like
a slow pace right like it's really being
taken in an exceedingly slow way in the
sense that it's designed just kind of go
through and give us like this really
basic idea of who this character is
damage had basically escaped and he had
fought Wonder Woman that was really kind
of like the the cool moment kind of
blasting onto the scene fights Wonder
Woman is able to hold his own and that
was kind of a big moment for his
character but from here what we end up
doing is shifting out to a plantation of
sorts where you basically have like you
know immigrant workers working and this
basically leads to like poison ivy kind
of busting up on the scene now this is
kind of the cool thing because what's
happening with poison ivy is actually
tying into the Batman comics and we'll
talk more about that here in a second
but again it really just kind of picks
up with the actual origin of even
himself with Ethan Avery now this is a
cool thing because in a lot of ways the
origin of damage is very reminiscent of
a combination of origins from both
Marvel and DC and when I say this I mean
like The Incredible Hulk Bane as an
example there's a lot of kind of
experience really experimentation in
terms of rolling this all together and
seeing how it all works and what we
already knew was that Ethan Avery was
basically a test subject he was a guy
who was kind of brought and for the
purpose of being part of this
quote-unquote
program now deal with this whole thing
it's designed to draw on a lot of these
different elements but that's the thing
here if you guys are looking at the New
Age of Heroes
it's basically DC sitting down and
saying okay fans that Marvel Comics want
this particular thing but if Marvel
won't do it we will and we'll just steal
their audience which is exactly what
they're doing and it's actually working
incredibly well like it's it's a really
really smart maneuver by DC to just
siphon off the audience from Marvel
Comics with that whole thing again it's
basically this idea that he was kind of
forced into it but Ethan Avery is the
first successful test subject of the
damage protocol following the whole
incident with Wonder Woman and really
his escape from the facility he's
basically been on the run that's really
the whole thing he's just kind of been
out there trying to stay under the radar
and keep away from like these various
you know members of the really the
various members of the of the military
community that are trying to seize
control of him more specifically Colonel
Jonas now again it's almost like this is
kind of like Ethan's own Thunderbolt
Ross so again you see a lot of these
themes sort of thrown in to the story
that are brought to bear from a lot of
the publications that have been released
so far but ultimately what is up
happening here is he finds himself
running we're really kind of stowing
away aboard a guy's border guys truck
and the guy somebody says look if you're
trying to get away and get under the
radar I've got a place where you can
earn some money and then just kind of
work there for a little while and then
eventually you know find passage
somewhere else to wherever it is that
you're looking to go it'll keep you away
from Colonel Jonas because for Ethan
Avery no matter where he goes he will be
found like Colonel Jonas we'll locate
him and the reason why is because she's
got a multitude of metahumans at her
disposal her own strike force more or
less which again is really kind of
reminiscent of like the old Nick Fury
but still one of these is for if
somebody named neat named Misha and
Misha has the ability to basically track
people to kind of pick up census
essentially you know to basically say I
can detect where they're going where
they've been and it's really cool here
because it's almost like a sort of
tactile ability to recognize where a
person's going and what they're doing in
this case one of the things she says is
that like a person who had basically
committed an assassination had stepped
on flour and she was able to locate
where this person like where they
stopped on the flour and then like all
the way back to where they were hiding
over the course of three months three
months after the assassination it
happened so it was a pretty cool thing
like a pretty big moment here but still
when you're dealing with this whole
thing is basically you know Jonah's just
trying to track him down is is really
all it is and that's kind of really in
this story I'd say it's more of a
background thing it's not really as
prominent as it was in the first three
issues it's just the idea that Ethan's
on the run from the feds so that's
really kind of what this means in terms
of how the stories being told the
problem with this is that when the
various workers alongside Ethan arrived
to this
plantation there's just forest growing
everywhere there's trees all over the
place and we end up finding out the
person who did this is poison ivy now
again it's kind of to be expected right
and that's why this works so well is
there's a there's a totally different
reason why Poison Ivy's doing this from
what we would expect in the sense that
normally her motivation is people are
bad plants are good she's like the
ultimate environmentalist and so with
this whole thing happening it's like
this idea that we would expect you just
kind of show up and say you've been
hurting trees you know and then punish
humanity because they weren't hugging
trees or something like that this is
exactly we would expect she'd have sorts
attacking people using various plants to
her disposal emitting pheromones
different things like that but she
hasn't met damage yet and that's the
funny situation is we would expect
damage to immediately be able to
overtake this but that's not the case
and that's really one of the first big
differences between damage and the
Incredible Hulk
because a lot of people have kind of
been making this comparison which they
really are designed to be I mean damage
is very much akin to like grey Hulk or
Red Hulk or The Incredible Hulk himself
deep very similar to those different
versions but really when you get down to
it in terms of like the subtle
differences the ability for damage to be
infected by pheromones that's a huge
difference and the reason why isn't is
it really direct myself and Sal
overcometh pop we're talking about this
and because the question we had here is
can the purple man make the Incredible
Hulk kill Avengers and the idea was well
he gives off pheromones so can the
incredible hoax healing factor override
the pheromones of of the purple man and
the only real the only one argument we
could come to you was presented when a
Spider Woman tried to use her powers her
ability to kind of make people fall in
love with her when she tried to use her
powers on Wolverine and it made him
dizzy
so that was probably like the extent of
it would you know regard to this
situation if this was the Incredible
Hulk it might work for a minute but then
like you would basically you know brush
it off and then just like go crazy on
poison ivy and just probably just start
beating her to a pulp with damage it's
not that way he's susceptible to these
kind of things it's basically saying
that like if he's exposed to something
that could basically override his
various senses then you could basically
take him out so he's not completely
invulnerable and so from here what we
end up doing when he's basically knocked
out and then taken by poison ivy we kind
of get this memory flashback and we're
basically shown this kind of this
basically you know initial controlled
test to see what it is East capable of
now this is a pretty big deal and the
reason why is because what the end up
saying is the entire damage formula is
actually derived from something called
mirror Club which is actually really a
derivative
the old Rex Tyler comics or really add
not really Rex Tyler comics but the old
like all-star comics I think it was like
either it was all-american or all-star
number 38 back in 1940 but it's
basically where our man comes from and
this was a really really cool idea and
it's actually pretty awesome because
what it does is it invokes like these
long-lost themes of DC Comics that
basically like the legacy of members of
the Justice Society of America continue
to live on our man was a guy from way
back in the day where he could basically
ingest mirror clothes and then has
essentially received like enhanced
vitality and and you know enhanced
strength but only for an hour and then
he had to have a recovery time of like
23 hours or something like that and with
this whole this whole concept is
basically built on that you know is it's
simply saying like we're taking this
concept of our man we have no idea where
our man is but we're taking this concept
of Rex Tyler we're gonna build on it and
then we're gonna create a weapon out of
it and that's how damage gets its power
that's why you have the one hour limit
is because for whatever reason he can't
go any more than an hour now the specula
a speculative explanation that's given
to us here is that it's because of the
limits of the human body that when a
person undergoes this transformation
you're talking about pushing the the
muscles in and strengthen you know all
that kind of stuff all to the physical
extreme and so if it were to go on for
longer than an hour we don't really know
what the effect would be we don't know
if the body wouldn't be able to handle
it anymore the heart would give out we
don't know if you know damage would
start to deteriorate on the cellular
level we have no clue what would happen
but that's kind of a cool thing here and
the reason why is because I have a hard
time imagining that DC wants to kind of
retread water with our map and so I
could I could see them saying this is
like a short-term limitation and the
reason why I say that's possible is
because if you're looking through this
you basically have you know Ethan Avery
talking to damage and damage talking
back so they're two distinctly different
personalities it's not like The
Incredible Hulk where you know Bruce
Banner doesn't really know what the hope
does hope doesn't really know what Bruce
Banner does depending on what you know
which ones in control it's really more
akin to like the cut like a like like
the kind of you know Lee Price venom
scenario in the sense of like the
Venom's of Venom symbiote talked to Lee
price and Lee price talked to the Venom
symbiote so it's is that's really kind
of how this thing works out and it's
actually pretty effective you know at
this point we pick up with Ethan himself
when he's basically met by one of the
guys and they say hey look you know I
saw you transform and and you can
basically help us the problem with this
is again it takes like 23 hours to
basically allow that to happen
the reason why is because he has to
build his energy back up now one of the
things that happens here is this does
not take place over the course of 23
hours instead he's actually fed some
basically sugarcane by this by this guy
who simply says hey look consume this
stuff and then you'll be fine
you know after which he basically starts
reverting back into damage he was able
to become damaging him so again it ties
into this idea that he doesn't really
have to have a 23 hour limit that is
really just like a huge amount of energy
that's sought from but what we end up
finding out here is that poison ivy is
not just hurt instead poison ivy is
actually working directly with Gorilla
Grodd which is kind of cool but also
kind of weird at the same time now if I
were a betting man I would say the
reason why this is the case is because
it allows DC to give damage this kind of
tour of the DC villain universe the real
heavy hitters like the the powerful guys
I mean with with someone like poison ivy
she's not powerful in and of herself
it's her ability that's happened to the
green and Miss her ability to basically
manipulate plant life that makes her so
powerful but someone like guerrilla
Grodd I mean he has the ability to
dominate the minds of other people and
so it's a way to kind of round out
damage himself and then basically
fast-track it you know he's you know
obviously has a weakness to various
pheromones and things like that that are
put off by poison ivy but did it becomes
Gorilla Grodd how powerful is damage in
comparison to somebody who has like
telepathy who can dominate the minds of
others well the idea here is that he's
basically powerless there really isn't a
whole lot he can do to stop Gorilla
Grodd because research going on this
rampage and tearing up the various for
you know tearing up the forces of
Gorilla Grodd as soon as Grodd seizes
control of damage he immediately stops
like he can't move and so that's kind of
the cool thing here there are
limitations to what his character can I
can't do they're basically saying like
we do not want to have to write this
character for 30 years and then find out
that we can't make good good stories
about him anymore because we've
basically done everything that they can
be told like we want longevity the other
side of this is that where you have
Grodd who is who really is kind of
controlling damage you end up having
poison ivy who sort of clicks out of it
she basically snaps out of whatever's
controlling her and then essentially
turns on broad and then from there like
Grodd essentially releases damage and
then damage starts to go on a warpath
and you know basically starts to tear
Grodd up but it's kind of a cool thing
is because damage was gonna kill Grodd
when you have a situation like this like
what this shows is that like damage will
kill like he'll kill anybody
but he'll kill people who get in the way
he'll just destroy them if he can you
know if it means that like he can keep
them from coming after him and so his
intention is to destroy
radda entirely but ultimately poison-ivy
kind of talks him down and says hey look
you got to stop and then from there
poison ivy just kind of like walks away
she's just kind of like look I'm no
longer under you're under the influence
what was controlling me you know
everything's cool you know you guys
everybody relax
I'm getting out of here you guys go back
to doing your thing I'll see you when I
see you and that's that's basically yet
you know with with her little tidbit
here now the explanation of what's
actually going on behind the scenes and
this is why this is so cool is you pick
up you know about 24 hours later after
even Ethan Avery wakes up and he's met
by Swamp Thing now this is kind of a
cool thing because Swamp Thing is kind
of like the like old man force right
like swampy he's been around forever and
he starts talking to Ethan and he's like
look man like I recognize the situation
that you're in right like I mean one
part of you is a monster one part of
he's a regular guy and that's fine but
even monsters tink can can do good
things it's all a matter of what your
intention is like what what you're
trying to achieve it could very well be
that because damage is a controllable
the best way to mitigate destruction and
the best way to use damage for good is
to drop him in a really terrible and
dangerous situations so that he can
fight the fights that nobody else can so
there's ways to make that work but the
other thing about this is that Swamp
Thing basically says there's this kind
of civil war among the green in DC
Comics if those you guys who don't know
the green is essentially nature that's
really what it is it's trees it's it's
plants any form of a tree Bush plant
anything like that
that's all tied in to the green and
what's one thing essentially says here
is that Swamp Thing has always been kind
of a caretaker you know more like a
peaceful being if he's provoked then woe
betide you but for the most part he's
just kind of a guy who likes to keep the
peace the problem with this is that the
green kind of looks at the world around
them and sees you know the progression
of humanity and industrialization it
says look they're basically tearing
everything out so the only way to fix
this problem is to destroy humanity and
that's what the green wants to do the
green wants to use Swamp Thing for the
purpose of destroying humanity
well swamp things not having any of it
and so in turn the green turned his
attention to poison ivy and began kind
of molding poison ivy into this kind of
soldier this sort of Avatar that will
essentially lead a war against the world
and basically recreate M night Shyamalan
- the happening but still like like with
this whole situation it is kind of cool
it is it is pretty interesting watching
this whole thing unfold I couldn't help
but laugh myself and I said that movie
that movie was ass it really it really
was it was bad movie was terrible at
night Shyamalan I thought it almost
destroyed his career but
anyway this works because again it kind
of shows that like there are other
things going on in the DC universe it's
slowly introducing him into the larger
DC landscape to give people an idea of
what his character is about what his
strengths and weaknesses are and then in
turn once he does face off against those
bigger characters point them back to
this when they can essentially get like
the whole explanation of what's really
going on but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]